So files are objects that we can write into and read from. Before we can read or
write into a file we need to open it, and we can do that using the built in open
operation, which takes a file name and a mode and it returns an instance of a
file. File is a built-in type. The file name and mode are strings. The file name
identifies the file. So for example we could do open Passing in gim.py gimpy as
the name of the file and as the mode we could pass in R for reading. As another
example we can use a full path name so we could use users/dave/ log.out to write
to the file log.out. There are different modes that we can use for example if
this is really a log What might make more sense is instead of using just the w,
which would replace what's there if you use w plus, it will append to what's in
the current logged it out file.